foreign
hello everybody Welcome to the
minimalist podcast where we discuss what
it means to live a meaningful life with
less my name is Joshua Fields Milburn
and I'm Ryan Nicodemus and together we
are the minimalists we're here with TK
Coleman what it is I'm Alabama's here hi
everybody we've got the rest of our team
in the studio as well coming up today on
this free public minimal episode we're
talking to a listener about some
minimalist budgeting tips we also have
an outstanding lightning round listener
tip and added value segment for you you
can check out the full three hour
maximal edition of episode 365 where we
answer four times the questions and we
dive deep into several simple living
segments that private podcast episode is
out right now at patreon.com the
minimalists your support keeps our
podcast and YouTube Channel 100
advertisement free because
advertisements suck let's start with our
callers if you have a question or
comment for our show give us a call
406-219-7839 or email a voice memo to
podcast at the minimalists.com our first
question today is from Nicole this is
Nicole from North Carolina so I've
worked through my values and so now I'm
generally spending money on experiences
versus stuff but I'm still dealing with
lifestyle inflation
so I doubled my income about a year ago
and of course my spending has followed
suit every month I have a thousand
dollars that goes towards my savings and
my debt and that's great but I know that
more could be going towards that
so I recently moved I'm in a city that I
love and I love to go out and explore
but I had to take it down a notch and
start cooking at home
either way I know what I'm you know I'm
taking the right steps towards my goals
but are there any tips you can offer
lifestyle inflation is an interesting
concept right because it's self-imposed
inflation in a way right and so Nicole
I'll tell you this that a rich person
with poor spending habits is still broke
now I know this firsthand Ryan knows
this firsthand from our corporate days
we made really good money a couple
hundred thousand dollars a year in
Dayton Ohio in the Audis we live like
kings well maybe princesses
[Laughter]
no we didn't that's the problem we
didn't live well at all because we were
overspending we were spending beyond our
limits and so when Ryan goes out and
gives a talk and and says minimalism is
really just living within your means ism
when you think about it that way it's
about intentionally using whatever
resources you have and that's where
Nicole is that's why Nicole I want to
applaud you for asking this question
because I'm not the type of person to
give prescriptions you all know this but
with something that's mathematical like
budgeting I think part of it is
understanding the math behind this how
much money do I make versus how much
money am I spending and then there's not
just the mathematical component the the
component that says here are the figures
but there's also the feelings that we
have around money and that is what
causes us to spend outside of our budget
so there's no prescription that will
change your feelings you need to have a
deeper understanding of what is causing
you to constantly inflate your lifestyle
I'll give you two or three examples here
the first one is certainly advertisers
that's why when we start this podcast
and we say advertisements suck it's
because quite often there are large
corporate entities or just other
entities who have their best interest in
mind and don't have your best interest
in mind the second thing I'll say here
is oh you know what we often tell
ourselves these stories about I'm
missing out if I cook at home but to me
cooking a home is one of the greatest
privileges I have because now I know I
don't have all the excess seed oils or
preservatives or junk that may be going
into the food at a restaurant because I
can control more variables at home and
so that's really what we're talking
about here is controlling the variables
that we can control it sounds to me like
Nicole's already accepted the things
that she cannot control yes of course
there's going to be regular real
inflation good luck trying to turn down
real inflation
but the most inflation we we experience
in our in our lives has to do with our
overspending our compulsive spending our
compulsory spending our impulse spending
oh I saw that thing so I should buy it
right now one last story for you I was
with I was with my daughter a few days
ago and we were walking through there
was this uh this beautiful festival and
we were walking and there was this
Crystal Store that she wanted to walk
into and I'm like okay we can walk in
there for sure
and we walked in there and she liked all
the little shiny crystals and everything
and then all of a sudden she saw this
ring and it just happened to be her size
and she puts the ring on it fits
perfectly and she's oh it's so beautiful
I really really really want it I know I
felt the power of the crystals
and she goes I know I said I wouldn't
buy anything
before we came in here but I really
really want it I said okay
would you be willing
to wait a day and see if you still want
it tomorrow and if you still want it
tomorrow we can come back we'll spend
half your money half my money on it
because she started her own business
recently she started dog walking
business at age nine nice calls by the
way and uh she's now taking on clients
and actually earning her own money five
dollars per dog walk and so she's made
over a hundred bucks so far and so she's
like trying to figure out what to do
with this money and I said okay I'll pay
for half you pay for half if you just
remind me a day from now well that was
two weeks ago and she hasn't mentioned
it once wow and why is that because she
put some distance between the impulse
and the purchase itself Ryan and I we
created this the 30 30 rule or called
it's called the wait for it rule if
something costs more than thirty dollars
we give ourselves 30 hours to make that
purchase it gives you that time to make
a decision because otherwise impulse
will take over and it will ruin your
life it will cause that inflation that
all otherwise wouldn't be there you just
had to spend money like a minimalist
spend less money than what you make boom
podcast over
shut it down drop the mic
but no I mean it's it is a simple
equation but as we know simple is not
easy
um and I think you know that's what
Nicole is trying to figure out here how
does she spend less than what she makes
um I love what you talked about uh
Millie about looking at it as a
privilege to like cook at home
um because I know for you and for Mariah
eating out actually is a detriment to to
her health it's a detriment to your
health sometimes for sure um I mean we
went to a Mexican place yeah and great
food awesome food she got
steak fajitas with like no
you know tortillas you know I think she
maybe she had like a bite of rice and
beans I mean it was all for all intents
and purposes like real whole food there
wasn't anything processed there
and it killed her and I was like oh it's
a seed oils I mean almost certainly
probably yeah but I'm like oh we can't
I'm like we can't eat out anymore like
we have to cook at home yeah um so yeah
we have found ways to like find joy in
cooking yeah
um but yeah I mean you know Nicole's
problem here this is a good problem to
have it's you know how does she she
doubled her income but how did she spend
like a minimalist it just goes back to
spending less money than what you make
and how do you do that you got to start
with the budget like that's 100 sure
yeah and I used to have um some friends
like mentoring clients uh and you know I
would I would uh they would talk about
very similar things that Nicole was
talking about and I'm like well do you
have a budget and um a couple times I
heard a budget like I don't need a
budget to know I'm poor like I'm poor
but I'm like if you don't know how poor
you are though like you're you're just
gonna keep spinning your wheels then
yeah yeah
um so yeah like I use uh Mariah and I
use every dollar that thing is awesome
it's funny because there's like a uh I
don't know how Rams is going to feel
about this how the Ramsey team is gonna
feel about this but the pro version
creates less friction to put um all your
purchases into like the different
categories yeah where like the free
version it creates so much more friction
because you got to pull your phone out
and like logging in every time you gotta
like uh you know I go to my um accounts
and I'm like okay like I gotta you know
keep track of everything Ryan's talk
about the every dollar app yeah the
every dollar app yeah yeah I did say I
did say we use every dollar right yeah
yeah so yeah that's uh there's like a
free version and a pro version
um yeah I highly recommend it like it is
it is Mariah and I used to use a
spreadsheet until we found out about
that there's there's a couple other
budgeting apps out there too but yeah
um that was a freaking Game Changer
especially when we moved to LA because
in Montana Mariah and I were paying off
debt so we were using a budget we
finally got debt free and it was awesome
uh and then I'm like oh we don't need a
budget anymore like we'll just you know
kind of go about it willy-nilly and then
we moved to LA I'm like oh no like we
have to have a budget like this is not
working yeah and the funny thing about
that is Ryan you and I both grew up
really poor and at some points like
significantly poorer than the people
around us even and we would have really
benefited the most at that time 100 from
a budget right 100 yes and I can tell
you that when I left the corporate world
took a 90 pay cut the only way I was
able to do that was to put together a
budget I made twenty three thousand
dollars in 2011. and the only way that I
was able to survive on that was to have
a budget because that budget helped me
identify what was non-essential what I
could cut out so that I could live this
life and I would no longer have to be
Tethered to some idealized lifestyle
yeah
Nicole congratulations on doubling your
income wow that doesn't just happen you
did something you did something you
stepped up you took some risk uh you
made some improvements so
congratulations on that that's that's
really cool what I would say is that
budgeting isn't just for
responsibilities it's also for
recreation you can not only plan ahead
or think ahead for responsibilities like
paying bills but you can also think
ahead for play and adventure and the
things that you like to do for fun
sometimes we associate preparation with
all the boring you know highly
responsible stuff because that's what
they make us do in school right if it's
something that someone else is making
you do you got to plan ahead you got to
write everything down and so we assume
that unless it's absolutely spontaneous
in every possible way it can never be
fun but you can still have fun and think
ahead about what the boundaries and
parameters are and so what I would
suggest is just like you have a budget
for All of the bills for how much you
want to save and how much debt you want
to reduce I would do the same thing with
the fund that you want to have apply
what I call the casino technique nothing
wrong with saying I'm going to go in the
casino and play around with some of my
money for fun but make your decision out
of the Heat of the Moment don't wait
till you get in the middle of a game of
poker to start making a decision about
how much you're okay with spending
decide before you go into the casino and
it's the same thing as you go into your
week how much do you want to spend how
much do you feel good about spending on
Recreation before you're in the middle
of doing all the fun things and making
your plans that's all I'll say yeah
here's one final practical thing for you
Nicole we have a Financial Freedom ebook
that you can download on our website if
you go to the minimalists.com click on
resources at the top there's a Financial
Freedom and it's the five steps that
Ryan and I took to develop a budget to
get out of debt and to stay out of debt
which is one of the most important
things because I had gotten out of debt
before in my early 20s and it got right
back into it like ah what's one extra
credit card and then all of a sudden you
have 14 credit cards yeah you get used
to those debt payments man and as soon
as you don't have any debt payments
you're instead of and I was there you
don't think about like oh now I could
save this money how much was I paying
each month on those credit cards 500
bucks 200 but whatever it is instead of
me going like oh that's going to go into
my retirement it was like oh now I can
afford more debt which if to say I can
afford debt is a it's kind of an
oxymoron right yeah yeah well here's one
more thing while you're over there on
that Resource page there's a bunch of
wallpapers you can download are
minimalist wallpapers one of them is the
five questions to ask before buying and
one of those questions is is this the
best use of that money and what Ryan
just illuminated there is yes maybe you
can't afford a 300 debt payment but is
that the best use of that four hundred
dollars five hundred dollars thousand
dollars a month yeah and if not it's
okay to say no to that thing so you can
say yes because money is a finite
resource even if you're wealthy your
money is limited right and so is this
the best use of that money for you at
this time and that wallpaper have it on
your phone or your computer before you
shop on Amazon or whatever just having
those five questions there and going
through it real quick that's an exercise
in avoiding impulse you can find those
over at the minimalists.com just click
the resources tab there at the top on
the private podcast coming up we also
have another question about inflation a
bunch of other questions as well Ryan
what time is it oh it's about 11 A.M
Pacific Time Oh you mean the lightning
round yes Josh it is time for the
lighting around when we answer your text
messages you can text your questions
your comments your smart alec remarks
your compliments to TK Coleman if you
want
937-202-4654 well I have some bad news
here Ryan oh I don't know if it's really
bad but it's just are you trying to
moralize news
I have some ugly news
unfortunate and some unfortunate news
here so during the lightning round this
is where Ryan TK and I do our best to
answer questions of the short shareable
less than 140 character response we put
the text to these minimal maxims in the
show notes so you can copy and share our
pithy answers on social media if you
like you can find all of those social
media pithy responses at the
minimalists.com podcast right there in
our show notes and when you text your
questions to us at the number Ryan just
gave it it goes to my phone and Ryan's
phone and and eventually TK's phone we
hoped and I say we hoped because I just
got the news from Community which is the
service we use community next where we
are able to have this service we pay 250
bucks a month we've been doing this for
years there's a lot of money to be able
to tax people right 250 a month yeah
well I just got the news from them that
it's going to go up to almost two
thousand dollars a month what wow so
we're just gonna give out TK's phone
number directly
and the unfortunate thing here is that
we were sending folks a Monday morning
minimal Maxim each week just so a nice
way to start your week off with a dose
of Simplicity and we're not going to be
able to keep doing that going forward
because of budgeting corporate greed
baby this is not the best use of our
1500 or 2 thousand dollars no even even
if we could afford it I'm tempted to
just be like no like you can't blackmail
us like that yeah I mean yeah there's
there's a couple companies and I won't
get into it now but there are a couple
companies who have done this and uh it's
slimy it's so slimy when you go up to
2000. by the time this episode comes out
did they explain why are they adding new
features are they is there cost of doing
business going up but what's going on
but they yeah they're a corporation and
they want to make money
the needle in our arm and they're like
you have or we have what you want and
it's going to cost you this now yeah and
so what I'll say going forward is you
can message us your lightning around
questions on Tick Tock Instagram
Facebook and and Twitter we're at the
minimalists and you'll find us there on
all of those platforms and you can
message Us for free we just can't afford
to keep spending even if we could afford
it I don't think that's the best use of
two thousand dollars a month and and so
I don't have any animus toward them the
the reason that they explained is there
are certain text messaging costs and
they're they're going to a per message
basis and because we have thousands of
people on that list every time we send a
text so I could do the service for about
200 bucks a month if we sent no tax
which wouldn't make a whole lot of sense
we could receive them but we couldn't
respond back right but we also couldn't
send large inspirational texts on
minimal maxims each week and really what
we're using it for we couldn't use it
the same way and to continue to use it
the same way that we're using it right
now to add value to people's lives it
would cost us way more than we're
willing to spend I was willing to spend
250 a month which is a big expense for
us every month but going beyond that is
just simply not in our budget what's the
name of the service provider community
so hey
to any and all competitors to community
I want to appeal to uh little
voluntarism a little entrepreneurial
thinking yeah if there are any
alternative Services out there that can
beat that deal we're open to considering
your offer this is a great opportunity
for a competitor to say hey I'll be
happy to steal that business by making
your customers happy in a way that
you're not willing to do I'm happy to
entertain what offers you have spoken
like a true Economist I love it now if
it was worth the two thousand dollars a
month I would totally be willing to give
Danny unknown a pay cut
that's not bad news it is ugly news
though yeah that is unfortunate man when
he said we hoped that we'd include TK on
this I thought he was saying because the
price was going up we're no longer gonna
be needing TK Services we need to go
back down we had to choose between TK
and texting we chose Texas now Josh you
and I used to work in Telecom
um how much money does it cost a phone
company to send it or receive a text
yeah and uh essentially nothing or data
like it's data and text message now
there's equipment cost there are some
costs I'm not trying to make it sound
free but once you have the equipment in
place like it's the fixed costs are
there the the nominal costs are so
minuscule but maybe they have text
messaging fees maybe they need to change
their Telecom provider a community to
get free text messages
anyway let's jump into our lightning
Round Here Taylor has a question for us
I just read an article about how some
big retail stores are considering
letting people keep items they want to
return while still giving them a refund
what does this say about the true cost
of returning some things you know the
cost goes Way Beyond the price tag and
not not buying a thing is letting it go
in advance so I prefer to not return
things I had to return something this
week and it drove me crazy I had to
return
a like little sculpture that we bought
because it was way too big and I had to
repackage it I had to go through like
the man I've taken to the FedEx store at
the waiting line and there are all of
these other calls up but man wouldn't I
have just saved had I not bought this
thing in the first place now it turns
out it was a thing that I wanted it just
didn't fit where I wanted it and so
you'll never get past it I understand
where some of these corporations are
coming from they don't want to deal with
all the logistics of returning however I
will say this that it probably will
incentivize some Bad actors to go in and
say I'll just return it yeah this
happens with Casper mattress now so if
you don't want that Caster mattress
they'll come donate it to your local
donation Warehouse then you can just go
buy it back for like fifty dollars yeah
instead of the thousand dollars you
spent on it and it incentivizes bad
behavior that is one of the knock-on
effects of inadvertently changing your
your process yeah yeah I shouldn't say
inadvertently but it's one of the non
effects of of changing the process and
not anticipating that that other result
yeah that's good
uh my Maxim here was a great businesses
value people over profits and so I think
there is a certain degree of when when a
company says all right you don't have to
worry about giving that back to us we'll
just send you a replacement the win-win
is that the company doesn't have to
worry about coming to pick it up and
dealing with all the logistics of
returning the item but you also don't
have to deal with being harassed over it
especially when it's something small and
I know for me there's there are fewer
things more irritating when than when a
provider gets it wrong and then I have
to do the extra work of getting the box
and boxing something back up and doing
this and doing that I want them to take
that you know um take that inconvenience
and so there's an aspect to it uh that
that's a win-win but you know I I really
think one of the things it says is that
the cost of replacing a customer is much
greater than the cost of replacing a
thing yeah that's the truth the best
businesses are the ones that don't argue
with you when you say I'm unhappy I'm
not satisfied with your product that's
why people love Chick-fil-A so much
right you can even if you lie and they
know they're taking that risk hey you
guys forgot my soda they're not gonna be
like no we didn't check right even
though they know you might be lying and
that's a risk they'll say no problem and
they'll just replace the item because
they understand that satisfied customers
outweigh the losses that come with
people that abuse the system there's
nothing like making customers so happy
that they're willing to go tell 10 other
people how awesome you are yeah so I I
think it's a it's a positive move and
that's something that gets overlooked
with entrepreneurship taking care of
your customers and making them happy and
not just trying to ding them for every
dime is actually good for business in
the long run it's the opposite of what
we're experiencing with the community
text messaging platform right yeah you
know maybe they can't afford to keep us
around because their business changed
substantially but at this point I simply
can't afford it you can't afford it you
can't afford it we can't afford it and
it's not the best use of our money yeah
uh yeah my pet the answer is this the
true cost of an item extends well beyond
the price tag so there's the cost of
storing the thing cleaning the thing
watering the thing fixing the thing
changing the batteries and the thing
refueling the thing changing the oil in
the thing replacing the thing uh and you
know so when it's all said and done we
we eventually get rid of the thing and
like that doesn't even include like the
psychological uh or emotional or even
the environmental costs of our things
when I hear something like this that's
what pops up in my mind like the Casper
mattress it's like oh wow like we look
at our finite resources as Expendable
like as a as something that we can just
kind of toss aside and let the land
landfill deal with it let the
environment deal with it yeah um but
yeah I mean this has always been an
issue with uh with the true cost
we've got so much more to talk about I'm
Alabama let's check in with our live
stream what questions do we have by the
way every Tuesday on patreon for our
video private podcast subscribers we do
a patreon live stream where you can ask
your questions and drop your comments in
the chat what do you got for us from
Alabama lots of love today and plenty of
questions we're going to start with
Lindsay with an E I've gotten so
accustomed to my current lifestyle that
things like Netflix HBO Max Etc are hard
to let go of how do we decide what to
cut out when things are already
accounted for in your budget I'm not
going to tell you how to do it Lindsay
but I'll tell you how I do it I will do
the scorched Earth approach you've heard
of burning Fields right it doesn't have
my name is Joshua Fields Milburn and I'm
often burning field so when Farmers burn
Fields so they can re-plan it it
re-fertilizing the land give it a break
to start from scratch and so I did this
recently with my subscription Services I
got rid of Netflix and Hulu I got rid of
Paramount plus and Apple TV and YouTube
premium and Spotify and apple music and
Pandora and title yes I had title as
well I had all of these streaming
services and so there was probably
around a dozen 1314 streaming services
that over the top over time I had
accumulated it didn't all happen at once
and so what did I do I got rid of all of
them a hundred percent of them and then
I just waited I didn't wait a month or a
year or whatever I just said I'm gonna
give myself some time when do I miss it
immediately YouTube premium I needed
that back because I hate advertisements
advertisements suck let's get rid of all
of these advertisers so I brought that
back and then oh yeah you know what I do
listen to a lot of music Apple music
made sense to me the streaming platform
great did that and then I waited waited
waited ah you know I don't really need
this I don't miss that at all I don't
miss Hulu I and all of a sudden you
realize like oh I only have two or three
or four streaming services now but I've
cut 10 of them out of my life and by
doing this regularly you don't have to
just do it with that but anything that's
in your budget if you have this giant
budget with a hundred monthly expenses
and you got down to zero would you
repurchase these monthly subscriptions
starting today and if you don't feel
compelled to do so let them go I love
that you and like what it started with
was getting rid of your internet when
you move up to Ventura County so like
that was really the foundation of like
well I don't have internet now so I'm
probably not going to need these
different Services
um so yeah I mean I would say you could
even take it a step further
um what what I've been practicing uh my
buddy taught me this
um
you can watch whatever you need to watch
on HBO Max or Paramount whatever the
streaming services that Lindsay
mentioned there and then you can cancel
your subscription and then if there's
something else you want to watch you
could sign back up for a month or two
later they would love for you to sign
back up in fact sometimes they give you
a better deal when you when when they
win back a customer so um yeah I mean
maybe that's a middle ground for you
Lindsay like when's the last time you
watched HBO match when's the last time
you watched Paramount plus and uh yeah
turn them off and turn them on when you
want to use them or never turn them on
again if you don't yeah yeah that's good
you just made me think about Spotify
like I gotta I want to be cool I want to
be cool so bad Josh
Spotify is inferior right so oh is it
not cool anymore I'm not saying that
it's way cooler but isn't that how it
works many of the cooler things are
inferior oh yeah apple music's uh the
with the lossless audio their audio as
long as you have it all turned on in the
settings their audio is so much better
than spotify's it's not even close what
does it say about me because like I was
just at at my aunt's place and I'm
talking to my little cousin she's like
13 she had a friend over her friend was
like 13 years old and they're listening
to Spotify and
um if I mention Pandora they look at me
like I'm a dinosaur like Pandora oh is
that on the radio back in the day
Grandpa anyway but what does it say
about me though like I really do hold on
to Spotify because I'm like yeah I am
cool I'm using with the kids for years
I use it to listen to Rogan every once
in a while but yeah um yeah I need to I
need to rethink some of these other
services I have too for sure I'm glad
this this topic I brought up Ryan's
walking in a row with the baseball cap
to the side hello fellow kids
with the back back on
what's up peeps
so have you discovered anything that's
the bomb lately
what's popping
one quick thing I'll say about this is
that there are fewer things we
underestimate more than our ability to
be happy without the things we already
wish we could get rid of and so a good
example of this is think about
compulsive habits or addictions you know
things that you just want to stop doing
stuff that you want to stop eating when
you're thinking about it hypothetically
oh but will I be able to live without
that that that pleasure that comfort
that luxury and and you already wish
that you could but you don't get to
experience that power and that Clarity
and that lightness and that freedom
until you do get rid of it right and so
I would suggest that Scorch Earth
technique where you say this I'm going
to get rid of them all and maybe I have
five of them and I'm gonna say I have
the permission to keep something like
one or two but here's my rule the next
thing I want to watch
if I sign up for it that's the thing I
gotta keep so if a movie comes out and I
want to watch it on Disney plus okay I
can sign up for Disney plus but if I do
that that's the one I'm keeping for a
year and that cost will make you say oh
do I really want Disney Plus for the
sake of this one movie or do I want to
wait on something I feel more excited
about it'll just introduce an element of
critical thinking to it that you might
find helpful we've got a bunch more
segments to get to we got our obsolete
objects we have the advertisement suck
segment will review a sucky ad this one
guys I can't believe it and it's not
even technically an ad but we'll we'll
get to it someone's selling pagers again
sort of oh man it's so bad that I turned
it into an app
we also have a home tour but we're
taking a detour we're going into the
studio doing a studio tour later on the
private podcast many more live stream
questions to check in with later in the
episode as well but Alabama what do you
got for us first here's a minimalist
Insight from one of our listeners
[Music]
Anthony from Harrison Ohio I'm calling
in regards to your May first episode
with Rich Roll about food I had a
comment and an added value
um my comment is that it was really nice
to hear from somebody who is vegan about
keeping things simple because I've
transformed over the past few months
um through my vegan journey and I've
discovered the same thing that just
keeping things simple when it comes to
food makes things a whole lot easier
it's not as hard as what you might think
in the beginning but in my beginning
phase of becoming vegan I did find a
Blog and
um a cook and Baker who
really adds a lot of value to my
my recipes and what I chose to add to my
daily intake of food and her blog is a
minimalist Baker her idea is that she
has the least amount of ingredients the
least amount of tools to make each
recipe and I have not had a bad recipe
from her blog yet you should check her
out all right y'all back to the public
episode real quick the minimal episode
we just spent nearly three hours going
through budgeting tips and new
decluttering rules but uh real quick for
right here right now here's one thing
that's going on in the life of the
minimalist this is before we get to our
added value segment which our added
value segment I'm getting super
practical in a moment but first right
here right now did you know that the
minimalists have a bunch of free
resources and I mean free free resources
just go to the minimalists.com and at
the top there's a little button there
that says resources it's a resources
page you can download our minimalist
rule book it's 16 rules for living with
less it's a free ebook we have a free
30-day minimalism game calendar you can
download you can print that out and it
shows you how many items it keeps track
of how many items you've gotten rid of
throughout the month we've got seven
free minimalist wallpapers so the five
questions to ask before buy we've got a
lessons now wallpaper we got a
minimalist wallpaper several others you
can download all those for free for your
smartphone or for your desktop nice
little reminder is to simplify declutter
your devices as well we've got the 15
ways to write better it's a free ebook
we've got the free values worksheet over
there as well if you want to get clear
on who you are it's about getting clear
on what you actually value as a person
what are your foundational values what
are your structural values what are your
surface values and worst of all what are
your imaginary values what values are
getting in the way you can download that
values worksheet and everything else I
talked about there the minimalists.com
just click the resources tab at the top
of the page for our added value segment
this week Jordan let's throw this up on
the screen this is
well when I moved earlier this year Ryan
you and I were hanging out me and you
and podcast Sean we went to a coffee
shop in Hollywood called sight glass
yeah and I realized like they had these
little paper towel dispensers they
didn't have this one but then I noticed
that
when I'm at home there are two things I
hate about paper towel dispensers well
at least two maybe more than that
first it's on the counter it kind of
looks ugly you put your paper towels on
the counter we all know it's not
aesthetically pleasing really right it's
fine it's not hideous but it's not great
but the second thing is when you have
them on a on a roll you're putting your
wet dirty hands on top and trying to
pull the paper you know what I'm talking
about right Ryan's got wet dirty hands
oh they're so dirty I love that you know
Rose silver paper towel holders I it's
like I I also I'm glad I don't but I the
piece of me really wishes I like could
pay attention like this to things but
yeah you're right I got wet dirty paper
towels
I'm talking about your wet dirty hands
Ryan they're so don't you King Shame me
anyway what I noticed is I used too many
paper towels when they're on the roll
and so I went ahead and bought this it's
this is not an ad obviously torque
Express countertop multi-fold hand towel
dispenser I bought this for my kitchen
at home and two things happened one is
whenever I need a paper towel I can just
simply grab one it's not ripping a bunch
off I don't have to touch a bunch of
things I just grab one paper towel and
yes I use paper towels occasionally but
what I'm using now I'm using far fewer
paper towels as a result which is not
something I expect so this thing is
adding value to my life because when I
do need a paper towel on the rare
instance that I do I'm not taking five
or ten or whatever I'm just taking the
one little sheet that I need I use it I
get rid of it there's no mess and so
this one thing in my life has not only
reduced My overall consumption but it's
made the experience much better it looks
so much better on my countertop and it
feels so much better in my life so we'll
put a link to this one in the show notes
for any anyone who is uh who might be
interested no we're not going to put a
link I want the company that makes these
to call me for sponsorship then we'll
post the link otherwise everybody's got
to figure out where to find it on there
oh my goodness yeah we don't get paid
for advertisements TK does
not a chance as we said earlier as we
said earlier on the private podcast I
don't like the taste of leather so I'm
not licking anyone's boots especially
Torque Express countertop multi-fold
hand towel dispenser
I'm just trying to get you paid for what
you're already doing that's so good this
non-boot looking segment is brought to
you by hey man they didn't pay me a damn
thing
irony everything we do is ironic I won't
lick your boots but I'll sell them for
you
by the way TK we got a bunch more
surprise questions on the private
podcast this week like what can I do
when inflation increases my fear of
missing out what do the minimalists
think about those new
50-year home mortgages
what is the minimalist new out in the
open rule for decluttering plus a
million more questions for the
minimalists and if you want to hear all
that visit patreon.com the minimalist to
check out the minimalist private podcast
or you can just click the link in the
description that's our show for today if
you leave here with just one message
let it be this
love people
and use things because the opposite
never works thanks for listening y'all
we'll see you next time
every little thing you think that you
need
every little thing you think that you
need every little thing that's just
feeding your greed or I bet that you'll
be fine without it foreign